the Jonathan Majors trial has been
delayed yet again however there might
actually be some good that comes out of
this and today we have some new
statements from Jonathan Major's team as
well as a record of what the judge said
today needs to happen in court by a
certain date or this case against
Jonathan Majors will be dismissed and
his team right now today has actually
filed yet again for this case to be
dismissed still claiming and further
claiming they have irrefutable evidence
that Jonathan Majors is indeed innocent
and the victim in the situation and we
have seen and heard about a lot of this
evidence if you're joining us today and
you're new to the story just a quick
little catch up a few months ago
Marvel's Big Star Jonathan Majors who
has betraying their new big bad villain
of the next few years for Marvel Studios
Kang the Conqueror was arrested he was
arrested for assault against his now
ex-girlfriend but current girlfriend at
the time of the alleged assault and
right now he is going to court for
misdemeanor charges of assault and
harassment and if he is found guilty
he's looking at a year Behind Bars a
year in prison what was said that
happened at first was that Jonathan
majors and his now ex-girlfriend Grace
Jabari were in a private car in the
backseat going to an event where they
got into a fight where he allegedly
assaulted her he was arrested the next
morning when the cops were called but he
is the one who actually called the cops
because he went back to his apartment
and he found her passed out half naked
on the floor when the cops got there he
was arrested that was all that was
revealed at first now we've learned a
lot more we have footage of Grace Jabari
minutes after this supposed assault took
place partying at a nightclub with no
signs of injury whatsoever footage of
Jonathan Majors actually trying to leave
her in the car and she's trying to hold
him back and make him not leave in which
he does escape and a lot of testimonial
Witnesses on Jonathan Major's behalf and
as far as we're concerned right now
Jonathan majors and his team has
provided a lot of evidence supporting
the fact that he did not abuse Grace
Jabari and as far as we know Grace
jabari's team hasn't at least publicly
shown anything evidence-wise but the
trial has been pushed back a few times
now including today but something new
did happen today this report is coming
from deadline.com and they state in a
rescheduled Hearing in New York City
today judge Michael Gaffey listened to
arguments from both the actor's defense
team and the Manhattan District
Attorney's office on the sharing of
evidence and Emotion by Majors as team
to dismiss the matter and what's really
interesting is that there are some new
court date and decision deadline set
that really coincide with Loki it's very
interesting but we'll talk about that in
just a bit to finish what the judge said
after he heard the defendant Jonathan
Majors team asked the matter to be
dismissed this is apparently what
happened no ruling on the motion was
issued Friday by judge Gaffey but the
criminal court judge has told the DA's
office that they have until October 6th
to respond to the defense's motion that
is the defense's motion to dismiss it
and according to this report the defense
will then have to reply by October 16th
with the judge making a ruling by
October 25th so this is extremely
interesting because what is now possible
is that the D.A could simply drop
everything against Jonathan Majors
Jonathan Majors is the defense in this
situation but since the very start of
this Jonathan Major's team has presented
a lot of evidence that is highly in his
favor so if they take a look at this and
they say you know what we're going to
lose this case let's just go ahead and
drop it right now that would obviously
be insanely good for Jonathan majors and
that's where we're at right now the DA's
office has to decide what they want to
do and how and if they want to move
forward and they have to decide by
October 6th and that's an incredibly
interesting date because that is exactly
when Loki season 2 episode 1 drops once
they make a decision then the defense
Jonathan majors's team has until October
13th to reply and that is when the next
episode episode 2 of Loki drops and then
the judge has until October 25th to make
a ruling which is about a week and a
half away now the reason that I
personally find these dates really
interesting and you've probably heard me
talk about this before but due to the
fact that they line up with release
dates for Loki makes me wonder what
Marvel Studios is thinking right now
because Marvel Studios has not said a
word about this entire situation
Jonathan Majors is the next Thanos he's
a huge part of Marvel and the MCU right
now and they put a lot of faith hope
work time into Jonathan Majors so one
it's really great that they haven't just
dropped him but two I'm assuming he's
taken all of the evidence with his legal
team and has presented it to Marvel
Studios and said look I am innocent in
this situation if he is that is but I'm
sure that's what he's telling them
please don't make a decision until the
court makes a decision because of
everything that his team is saying is
true and all the evidence they have if
that's all real then his team probably
feels extremely confident that he's not
going to be found guilty however we have
heard from some insiders like Alex P at
the cosmic circus that Marvel Studios
does have a backup plan for Jonathan
majors and that if they are going to
replace Jonathan Majors they might
actually show us a new king at the end
of Loki but the trial has been pushed
back a few times now and it's getting
really close the judge has to make a
ruling by the 25th and the last episode
of Loki episode 6 airs on the 10th of
November now this could be purely
coincidental and disclaimer this is just
my speculation at this point but I gotta
wonder if Jonathan majors and his legal
team said hey Jonathan majors has
already lost a ton of work because of
this his reputation has been tarnished
his name's been tarnished and if this
trial continues to go on he could lose
another job one at Marvel Studios again
that's my speculation that might have
been said or not but those dates are
really coincidental and it really could
just be coincidence but Jonathan Major's
team does seem very certain that they
are going to win this here are some new
statements released by Majors team his
lawyer Grace Jabari stated this from the
beginning of this case the people have
had incontrovertible evidence that
Jonathan Majors is innocent of these
charges that Grace Jabari was not
injured by him at all and that Mr Majors
is the real victim of several crimes
perpetrated by Mr Bari and she even made
claims that Jonathan majors has been
denied his right to a speedy trial she
continued to state in fact the NYPD has
determined there is probable cause to
arrest Grace Jabari with the crimes she
committed against Mr Majors but rather
than dismiss false charges against an
innocent black man the people instead
have willfully withheld evidence of his
innocence varied evidence proving that
his white accuser is lying and
interfered with the nypd's attempts to
investigate and arrest Miss Jabari and
from what we've heard Majors legal team
says that there is police body cam
footage of the police telling Grace
Jabari to say that Majors assaulted her
we're unsure if this is true or not but
that is what their team States happened
so right now it's kind of all or nothing
it's them saying this is all of the
evidence make a decision on whether you
are pressing forward or dropping this
case but all evidence must be submitted
and come to light everything is going to
be used so right now the D.A has to
decide how they're going to move forward
then Jonathan Majors team will reply to
that and the judge will make a ruling by
October 25th on how everything is going
to play out so it's big news because it
seems like the case has a chance to be
dismissed especially if the DA's office
is really looking at all of the evidence
and if everything that majors's legal
team has said is true all of the
evidence they have if that is real then
it seems like they do have irrefutable
evidence that Majors is innocent and if
that all really is the case then the D.A
might just drop the case entirely so
that's where we're at right now the next
update should come October 6th however
the D.A could make a decision before
then they just have until October 6 to
do so of course if we hear anything
we'll let you know because everybody
right now is wondering if Jonathan
Majors will remain Kang the Conqueror in
the MCU so don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest updates
you can also subscribe and leave a
comment on our videos for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
the winner picks one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
thank you